good morning everybody thank you for
coming my name is Bob steagle and I'm
here to talk about a proposal written by
guy Davidson and myself to include
facilities for linear algebra in the
standard C++ library as always my talk
is sponsored by the American East code
East constellation of America an
important trade association everyone
should belong to all right structure of
the talk I'd like to give a little bit
of background I assume that if you're
coming to a talk on linear algebra you
probably have a good handle on the
fundamentals and I'm not going to spend
a lot of time lingering on that I'd like
to talk about some high-level goals that
guy and I set out for ourselves as we
began developing the proposal I'll
provide some important definitions and
the reason for doing that is to provide
disambiguation between the different the
different uses of overloaded terms I'll
then talk a little bit about the aspects
of designing the interface that's part
of the proposal and how those design
aspects the exploration of those aspects
led to a definition of the this proposal
scope and the requirements that we tried
to fulfill as we wrote the proposal also
talk I'll then move on to talk about the
interface design itself I will give a
sort of top-down recursive demonstration
walking through some compile-time
computations to show how it works or how
its intended to work I'll then give a
handful of demonstrations of how one
could customize the behavior of the
library if if it's implemented according
to this interface and a quick
description of things that are yet to be
done you know what's on our to-do list
so this is a discussion of P 1385 right
now if you look on if you look it up on
W g21 link that right now provides the
r1 version guy Davidson and I are
currently in the process of writing r2
to present at Cologne in a few weeks
our one is pretty much out of date
already at the end of the talk I'll give
you if you're interested I'll give you I
provide a link to my github account
where you can watch the work in progress
if you so desire
as I mentioned my co-authors Guy
Davidson and Michael Wong who is the
chairman of s g14 was kind enough to set
up a little specialized linear algebra
study group which I I run the call it's
once a month a handful of people dial in
we talk about P 1385 and other ideas
surrounding it and some other proposals
as well if you're interested in linear
algebra are participating in that
discussion I encourage you to follow the
s g14 reflector and I make announcements
for the calls the call is the first the
first Wednesday of the month so should
look on the reflector around that time
all right so a little bit of background
I'm not a mathematician and I don't play
one on TV so I'm going to keep this
brief so it's not to embarrass myself
what is linear algebra well the most
succinctly easiest to understand
definition for me that I could find was
from the fount of all knowledge
Wikipedia the branch of mathematics
concerning linear equations and linear
functions and their representations
through matrices and vector spaces I
came to learn that linear algebra is
central to many areas of mathematics and
in fact geometry can be formulated in
terms of linear algebra I did not know
this and I don't know how it's done but
Wikipedia tells me it so and thus I
believe it it is a useful mathematical
discipline for science and engineering
of course many phenomena are modeled
using linear equations in linear algebra
over the years the state of the art has
evolved in a way that you can provide or
you can perform computations incredibly
efficiently efficiently with linear
algebra and of course it's used in a
whole bunch of areas in life and this is
just a few you know graphics machine
learning finance analytics medic
Imaging which is where I used it a few
jobs ago signal processing nuclear
simulations all kinds of things if
there's a thing that requires some sort
of mathematical modeling
it's like linear algebra is almost
always the first tool that people start
using so as we set up thinking about
what an interface should provide we
wanted to look at it from the point of
the user
remember the proposals for the standard
and for the library describe proposed
interfaces not implementations so we are
attempting to provide an interface that
means certain requirements and is also
implementable according to those
requirements so let's look at the
requirements from the perspective of
everyone everyone that uses this what
are they going to want to use what are
they going to want to have well they
want it to be easy to use it should be
easy to use there should be some aliases
or types which you can instantiate and
go to work quickly and get something
done right it should not be difficult to
start using it should be expressive you
should be able to create expressions
that are similar to what you might write
with pencil and paper and have them work
it should have reasonably high
performance I don't think any
implementer is going to be capable of
providing the best possible performance
on whatever platforms they support but
our goal is to provide an interface that
is implementable in such a way that the
performance that an implementer can
provide is pretty darn good for 90% of
uses however there's a group of super
users of linear algebra and here I'm
thinking of my friends from the National
Labs they want customization they want
customization they want performance
customization high performance and they
want customizable high performance and
they want support for what I think of as
being non-traditional computing
environments linear algebra computations
that occur across multiple machines in a
distributed environment not just on a
single GPU or a single CPU
so let's talk about some of our goals
well we hope with this proposal to
provide a set of vocabulary types
describing linear algebra and we want to
provide a public interface that's
intuitive that is teachable that is
customizable and also that mimics
traditional mathematical notation and as
I mentioned a few seconds ago we want to
exhibit competitive not ultimate but
competitive out-of-the-box performance
so let's talk about customization in
terms of customization would like to
provide through this interface a set of
building blocks for managing memory the
source of memory ownership lifetime
layout access managing other resources
in this case we're thinking of execution
contexts that might be used in
distributed computing or with executives
you know that is on the on the to-do
list and also building blocks for
representing other interesting math
types like tensors or quaternions we'd
like to provide a set of straightforward
tools to allow users to customize the
behavior of the library we want to
enable users to optimize performance for
their specific problem and their
specific hardware and we want to be able
to do that by providing a reasonable
level of granularity to perform that
customization and I hope by the end when
I show you some of the examples of how
behavior can be customized you'll be
convinced that we're on the right path
ultimately we want users to only be
required to implement a minimal set of
types and functions in order to do the
customization to solve their problem oh
go through some definitions quickly so
linear algebra we think of it as being
the study of vector spaces and a vector
space is a collection of vectors where
these are objects that can be added
together and multiplied by scalars when
I think of vectors I think of Euclidean
vectors in three-dimensional space as a
physics major of course you use vectors
to represent displacements electric
fields forces momentum
from a mathematical perspective the
dimension of a vector space is the
number of coordinates that are required
to specify any point within that space a
matrix from a mathematical perspective
is a rectangular arrangement of numbers
or symbols or expressions that's
organized in rows and columns and of
course we all know that a matrix that
has R rows and C columns is said to have
size R by C matrices are useful because
they provide a way of representing
linear transformations from one vector
space to another at the end of the day
that's kind of what they do an element
is an individual member of that
rectangular arrangement of things that
comprise the matrix elements are indexed
in such are use traditionally used one
based indexing so the row index varies
from one to are inclusive and the column
index varies from one to see inclusive
and of course there's matrix notation
that you know a11 is in the upper left
hand corner and AARC is the element in
the lower right-hand corner a row vector
is a commonly used shorthand for a
matrix that contains a single row it has
size 1 by C the matrix the rows of a
matrix you know are sometimes called row
vectors in this in this version of the
interface we do not distinguish between
row vectors and column vectors which
themselves are matrices that represent a
single column of another matrix the rank
of a matrix is the dimension of the
vector space that's spanned by its rows
and columns so if you have a 3 by 3
orthogonal matrix it has rank 3 if you
have a
if you had a 3 by 4 matrix the highest
possible rank of that matrix would be 3
and from linear algebra of course we
know that the the rank is equal to the
maximum number of linearly independent
rows or columns all right these are not
some quite we use these in turn thinking
about math there was a little bit of
hesitation whether to include the next
set of terms is math or C++ terms I just
we decided to lump them under math so we
think of the term element transforms as
being non arithmetic operations that
modify the relative positions of
elements and matrix like a transpose a
column exchange or a row exchange we're
going to call those for the purposes of
defining our interface we're going to
call those element transforms element
arithmetic we're going to find this as
being the operations that read or modify
the values of individual elements
independently of other elements and
we're going to define matrix arithmetic
as being some arithmetic operation which
occurs on matrices or vectors in their
entirety instead of individual yes yes
they would fall under both element and
matrix wise right we make these
distinctions too to sort of you'll see
when we get to the next slide we make
these distinctions to provide a cut off
in the set of the requirements that we
provide
okay so decompositions well
decompositions you know there's no
formal definition but we define them as
being complex sequences of arithmetic
operations element of Earth meticulous
forms all of those previous three things
that are performed upon a matrix to
determine important mathematical
properties of that matrix one might do
an Lu decomposition in order to back
solve a problem or determine you know if
if a square matrix you
in fact you know has full rank eigen
decomposition this is a term that we use
just to lap to to lump all sorts of
computations for determining the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues of the
matrix and we just lump this under this
term eigen decomposition for now so now
let's turn to a c++ perspective a tight
design perspective rather than than math
so for the purposes of this paper and
throughout the rest of the presentation
i'm we use the term math object
generically to mean one of the two c++
types matrix or vector that are
described in the interface we use the
term storage as a synonym for memory and
mostly because memory has a specific
connotation and one might think of
storage as being slightly more general
than Ram so we use the term storage
we use the term dense to mean a math
object whose representation has storage
allocated for every element we use the
term sparse in the in the opposite sense
to mean a math object with storage
that's allocated only for its nonzero
elements yes David that's up to how you
decide to implement them and those are
actually the the thinking about things
like upper lower triangular banded
symmetric matrices actually fall beyond
the scope of our proposal okay so
another important term is that of
engines and engines in our conception
our implementation types that manage all
of the resources associated with a math
object on behalf of the math object
these include things like elements
storage ownership and lifetime access to
individual elements be it read-only or
read write resizing and reserving
elements if necessary or appropriate
execution contexts at some point in the
future in this design in this design of
this interface an N
object is a private member of some
containing math object a matrix contains
a matrix engine other than appearing as
a template parameter engines do not
participate in the math objects public
interface they provide private
implementation but they don't
participate in the interface yes only as
a template parameter
they are stateful potater they they
don't participate in the interface
everything everything necessary for
constructing to that their state is
forward to them from the enclosing math
object maybe you'll see when we get to
the code math objects own engines
engines may or may not own the resources
they manage okay all right so what's
traits type we're all used traits we're
all familiar with traits
I think of traits as being a stateless
class usually stateless a class or class
template whose members provides an
interface that's normalized over some
set of types or template parameters a
canonical and very early example of
traits as char traits which are used for
stood string right they often appear as
parameters in class or function
templates and this interface proposal is
no exception row and column capacity
excuse me
these two we use these terms to mean the
maximum number of rows and columns that
a math object could possibly have and we
use the terms row size and column size
to mean the number of rows and columns
respectively that a math object actually
has and of course the row size and
column size has to be less than the less
than or equal to the corresponding row
and column capacities
both it depends on the engine it does
have the same meaning you'll see I'll
come back to it if you still have the
question when we look at the interface
come back and ask again we use the term
fixed size to mean an engine type whose
row and column sizes are fixed and known
at compile time we use the term fixed
capacity to mean an engine type whose
row and column capacities are fixed and
known at compile time a dynamic
dynamically resizable refers to an
engine whose row and column sizes and
capacities can be changed and set at
runtime so let's disambiguate some terms
the word matrix is frequently abused by
C and C++ programmers to mean a
general-purpose array with some
arbitrary number of indices right we
hear it all the time we specifically use
the term matrix in you know that font to
mean the mathematical object and in the
fixed size font to mean the C++ template
that models the matrix mathematical idea
we use the term array to mean a single
or multi-dimensional array in the C++
sense which itself has no invariants
that pertain to some higher-level
meaning or other other invariants an
array has elements and there is no
invariants between the elements
themselves whereas in a matrix that that
may be different along the same lines
vector and I ranted last year for a
little while about how I dislike the
term vector is also abused by
programmers in our field to mean a
dynamically resize one dimensional array
again we use vector to mean the
mathematical object or the type that
models that object and we use the term
linear array to mean a single
dimensional array in the C++ sense now
this is a tricky one in programming the
term dimension often refers to the
number of indices that are required to
access the elements in an array or an
element of an array in linear algebra
however a vector space V is said to be
n-dimensional if there exist n linearly
independent vectors basis vectors
perhaps that span V so two different but
very closely two different but related
meanings we use dimension in both senses
and unfortunately there's no way really
to use different terms for it so for
example a vector that describes a point
in an electric field it's a one
dimensional data structure implemented
as a three dimensional vector it
represents a vector in a three
dimensional space but the data structure
is one dimensional because you use one
one index to access its elements
similarly a rotation matrix that might
be a three dimensional rotation matrix
that might be used in a game engine is a
two dimensional data structure because
you use two indices to access its
elements composed of three dimensional
row vectors or column vectors that
represent the vector space upon which it
operates rank is another tricky one of
course it's used in linear algebra to
represent the dimension of the space
span span by the rows or columns in
tensor analysis rank is often used the
word rank is used as a synonym for a
tensors order the C++ standard uses the
term rank as a synonym for dimension and
there it is the the section and the
quote we avoid using this word our first
linear algebra calls were quite
confusing as we were talking about the
ranks of matrices and the ranks of
arrays and the ranks of tensors and it
got to be too much
then you don't use dimension twice I
could do that but I have to I have to
arbitrarily pick a pick one meaning of
rank and the other four dimensional well
it could be that that Loog forces us to
make that choice alright so let's think
about how we're going to design this
thing memory memory of course is
important storage so what are some
aspects about memory that we need to
think about well of course the location
of memory the memory used by a math
object can be in some external buffer
that's allocated from a global heap or a
custom allocator it can be in an
internal buffer that's part of the math
object itself it could exist collect it
can refer collectively to a set of
buffers distributed across multiple
processes or multiple machines right so
we have to think about where is memory
located we have to think about the
addressing model to get to that memory
if you've seen my talks on fancy
pointers you know I like to talk about
addressing models the memory that's used
might be addressable via some sort of
fancy pointer maybe I'm doing some sort
of machine learning thing and I want to
put my linear algebra stuff in a shared
buffer so that my you know my my
autonomous vehicle can have input to one
side of the shared matrix from input and
another side reading it and processing
it ownership a math object might own and
manage its memory or a math object might
through its engine might use a Const or
mutable view to memory that's managed
and owned by somebody else we need to
think about capacity and resize ability
which is why I introduced those terms
earlier in some problem domains it's
useful for a math object to have excess
storage capacity so that resizes don't
require reallocations when I worked in
functional MRI we had a problem where
every four seconds we had a every two to
four seconds we had a new sample coming
in we were doing multiple linear
regression in a highly over determined
problem we'd have regressor matrices
that were on the order of two to five
hundred rows with maybe ten to twenty
regressors in the columns so it's a very
highly over determined problem every
time a new sample point came in there
would be a new row
and the regressor matrix and new rows in
the matrix that represented the signal
we'd end up doing an SVD and computing
the beta's anyways the point is that
every if I had to resize the regressor
matrix and the data matrix every time a
new sample came and I'd be wasting a lot
of time so we had excess capacity and we
would size in to that capacity just like
you do with vector it depends it depends
on your application for fMRI analysis
it's critical right for games it is not
know you can resize you can resize
columns and rows I've done it
you can add patio right you can add
padding's to the rows you can add
padding's to the columns so as I just
mentioned another problem domains like
graphics math objects are small they're
fixed size they never need to be resized
element layouts another consideration in
C and C++ the default from for arrays in
U which you might use to represent a
matrix is row major dense and
rectangular in Fortran the default at
least many years ago when I did Fortran
the default was column major I don't
know if that's changed okay one of the
universal constants like EE or H bar
okay
you might have element layouts that
correspond to matrices that are upper
lower triangular matrices or banded and
of course element layouts might be
sparse we think about element types the
types of the elements themselves C++
only provides a small set of of
arithmetic types that you might want to
put into a matrix sometimes you want to
use other types
lots of people right now are working on
on additional types that represent
numbers in some way that they they have
proposals for in front of the Committee
fixed-point calculations types that do
arbitrary precision floating point John
MacFarlane has an interesting proposal
for something
he calls elastic integers you have
complex numbers which are part of the
standard so you know float and double
and long double are not the only
interesting things keeping in mind that
an element type may actually have to
allocate memory suppose you have some
flexible high precision floating point
number
individual elements might allocate
memory so the implementation and the
interface cannot assume that elements
are trivial types right which makes
managing the padding interesting right
not impossible
here's where we really get into the into
the weeds expressions with mixed element
types in general if you have multiple
primitive types int float double in an
arithmetic expression in a sense the
resulting type is the largest of all
this types it's the type with the most
precision or that can contain the
results of the computation and the
principle behind that is that
information should be preserved in an
expression so in our interface we call
the process of determining the resulting
element type in an expression in a
binary expression element promotion
we'll see some examples of that yes so
the question is do we have any
requirements about elements having some
relationship or dependency on other
elements close to them no we do not
I do we will allow aliasing we don't we
don't comment on the subject of aliasing
otherwise there's no way to implement
some of the algorithms you proposed
because you need to know when you apply
a scale to an element
oh I see what you're saying I've not
thought about that I'd have to sit and
think about it but now that you now that
you say it David I think I I think I
agree with you yes okay let me move on
because I've got a lot to get through
here
okay so consider that consider whether
the situation where you have an
expression with mixed engine types I
have a matrix that has a fixed size
engine and I'm adding to it a matrix
that has a dynamically resizable engine
right what is the resulting engine type
of my result what should it be in
analogy with that of the idea of element
promotion we believe that look at that I
spelled general wrong the resulting
engine should be at least as general as
the most general of all of the engine
types that participate in the expression
and we call this process determining
what the resulting engine type is engine
promotion let's think about arithmetic
expressions users are going to want to
optimize specific operations they may
want to do a sim D based matrix matrix
and matrix vector multiplication you
know the example I always think of in
this case is affine transforms for game
programming where you've got maybe some
optimized 4x4 representation to
represent you know rotation translation
scaling shearing and you want some fast
multiplication for that right well two
operands in an expression may be
associated with different customizations
and if that's the case we have to decide
which customization to apply to the
specific arithmetic operation and we'll
see an example of that we call that
process operation trades promotion so in
an arithmetic expression where you have
a mate two matrices let's
they were adding them the matrices have
some element type they have some engine
type and associated with each of those
object is some proposed set of
operations if I have two matrices and
they have those types are different
between them somehow I have to resolve
the differences between elements the
engines and the customized arithmetic
operations that go with them those are
the three kinds of per per motion that
the proposal covers so taking all this
into account we developed the we made
the following statement of scope and set
out the following requirements first of
all is a statement of principle we think
the best approach for standardizing this
set of facilities for C++ 23 which is
our target is an approach that's layered
iterative and incremental and
consequently this proposal is one for
very basic linear algebra stuff only we
think it provides a minimal set of
components and arithmetic operations
necessary to provide a reasonable basic
level of functionality higher level
functionality can be built upon this
proposal and we strongly encourage
people who are interested to do so we
want to if you're interested in doing
this we want to hear your feedback about
how easy or difficult it is to build
some higher level facility like let's
say a generic SVD that you'd have to be
very ambitious but let's say you wanted
to try that upon the the facilities that
this proposal provides from an abstract
perspective at a high level you know we
want to provide a set of types and
functions to perform basic matrix
arithmetic in finite spaces not infinite
spaces so we need facilities for
determining whether a type can be a
matrix element we need types that
implement engines that manage storage we
need types that model matrices row
vectors and column vectors we need we
need support for element transforms
remember that's manipulation of the
location of elements in the matrix we
need support for elementary thematic
modifying individual elements of matrix
we need support for possibly mixed type
matrix arithmetic we'd like to make it
easy to use and extensible from a more
concrete perspective we need to model
these mathematical ideas we use traits
types to validate element type we use
class templates to implement engines we
use class templates to implement
matrices and vectors we provide
arithmetic operators for addition
subtraction and negation of matrices and
vectors we provide arithmetic operators
for scalar multiplication of matrices
and vectors and arithmetic operations
for non scalar multiplication of
matrices and vectors ie matrix matrix
vector matrix matrix vector vector
vector sort of yes our original proposal
and if you read our one you'll see there
were there were distinct types row
vector and column vector and the reason
for that was my pedantic need to
distinguish between inner product and
outer product in our one a row vector
times a column vector gave you an inner
product and the result type was a scalar
a column vector times a row vector was
an outer product and gave you a matrix
our review and kkona revealed that
people thought that I was being too
pedantic and no one cared about that
just that difference and that no one
really cares about the outer product in
real life so let's just have one vector
type and vector vector multiplication
will be the inner product outer product
will be a named function that will be
part of a succession paper so concepts
are on the to-do list right having
watched Eric and Casey struggle with
concepts definition for ranges we
decided not to tackle that initially
right it is definitely on the radar it's
something that needs to be done for now
though we wanted to get other parts of
the interface working so we want to make
it flexible we
traits types to ensure that mixed type
expressions are supported we want to
make it relatively the extensibility to
be relatively easy to use by providing
facilities for integrating new element
types for customizing engines for
integrating custom implementations of
arithmetic operations and we want to
minimize the number of customization
points in namespace stood in this
proposal there are two customization
points which are traits types that exist
in namespace stood that a user may want
to specialize along the lines of say
allocator traits or pointer traits right
considered but excluded there was a long
discussion about tensors we decided to
exclude tensors from this and
concentrate only on linear algebra
concepts the reasoning without spending
too much time on it was as follows every
rank two tensor can be represented by a
square matrix yes but not every square
matrix is a tensor the class invariance
and the public interface are different
between those of a matrix and a tensor
so matrices are not Liskov substitutable
for tensors and because the
substitutability did not not apply we
decided just to punt on the concept of
tensors that are the I'm sorry not the
concept with a Big C the idea of
supporting tensors right we also had
discussions about supporting quaternions
well quaternions model very different
ideas for math than vectors right or
matrices and also their invariants in
public interface are different from that
of vectors
once again Liskov substitutability does
not apply so we punted on this issue as
well that being said there's no reason
why a quaternion could not be an element
of a vector or a matrix because it
certainly has the requisite non
commutative ring properties but we are
not implementing those as part of this
proposal yes
yes so the comment is is that the
standard library is the only place where
a quaternion implementation should occur
because it needs to be reinterpret
castable to an array of floats or
doubles or whatever the underlying
element representation is right okay
this is going quickly the interface and
the components I'm going to go through a
high-level description of the interface
I'm gonna blow through it it's actually
very straightforward I hope that it will
all make sense and not provide any major
surprises to you I think the interesting
part will be when I get to the to the
recursive the recursive discussion of
how those facilities are decided
designed to work together
so I mentioned engines these are types
that manage resources they manage memory
that manage element access and update
engines don't need to be owning they can
be views and I'll show you an example of
the transpose engine which is simply a
view it swaps the indices in the
indexing operator the math objects model
mathematical abstractions they use
engines to manage the elements the they
they exist to provide a consolidated
interface to the arithmetic operators so
they don't have to have a different set
of arithmetic operators for every engine
instead I just have a small set of
arithmetic operators from matrix and
vector and underneath the hood matrix
and vector implement their functionality
using different engines operators
provide the desired syntax we provide
for operations addition subtraction
multiplication and negation traits types
support all of this stuff and the mental
picture that I have oh and by the way
the traits types are used to provide to
perform type computations at compile
time and the arithmetic traits perform
runtime computations of a stick matrix
arithmetic so the picture I have in my
mind is this on the outside you've got
the main the main user visible pieces
which are the
the math objects and the arithmetic
operators and in the middle keep you
know acting as glue making it all work
are the traits types so thinking about
traits
there are several several categories of
traits different sets of traits that
have different missions to support this
numeric traits these are traits which
specify and they test the properties of
types that purport to be numeric we
provide a numeric traits customization
point providing full or partial
specialization by the user to specify to
opt in and specify my type foo is an
arithmetic type it's legitimate to use
it as an element of a vector or a matrix
it's a very simple thing to do
element promotion traits these are
traits that perform the process that
worked the compile time process of
determining the resulting element type
from an arithmetic operation engine
promotion traits they solve the problem
of deciding what's my resulting engine
type of a fixed-size engine and a
dynamically resizable engine I have to
compute a resulting engine what's it
going to be engine promotion traits make
that dessert determination we have
arithmetic traits which determine the
resulting type and value of an
arithmetic operation we have operation
traits operation traits are sort of a
global container that contain the
element promotion ends a promotion and
arithmetic traits that are to be
associated with an operand and when you
see the interface hopefully that will
make sense the operation traits are a
template parameter to matrix and vector
and finally we have the second
customization point what we call
operation selector traits these are
traits that are used by the operator
implementation to select the operation
traits of the resulting type I'm adding
two matrices for the resulting matrix I
need to know the element type the engine
type and the type of the operation
traits that are going to be associated
with my resulting matrix as a
this is this is the second customization
point one of two there are also a wide
variety of implementation specific
private traits I'm not going to go into
those they employ the usual host of
fundamental meta programming tools of
particular interest and if someone
remembers reminds me at the end we use
type detection a lot under the hood to
make something very interesting happen I
didn't make any slides about that
interesting stuff because that's almost
another presentation so yes so the
question is do we have a spatial concept
of spatial promotion traits that would
allow one - OH - promote a
two-dimensional vector into a
three-dimensional vector no that sort of
promotion is handled by resize okay so
the numeric element traits I'm going to
run through this very quickly so at the
top is a traits type number traits this
is that when I mentioned a customization
point this is the specific thing that
one might customize we have some new
predicate traits types is complex is
field is ring is non commutative ring
and finally is matrix element this is
the predicate type that the engine used
to determine whether or not the thing
you're trying to instantiate me in terms
of is in fact suitable to become an
element there's some discussion about
whether is matrix element is really
necessary or not for the purposes of
this discussion I'm going to say yes it
is you could not instantiate a matrix of
string it's a type predicate I'm sorry
so the question is are the predicate
traits and by predicate traits I mean
the ones that begin with is underscore
right the predicate traits are not
intended to be customization points the
predicate traits that exist in stood
right now under type traits are not
customization points right the only to
customization points well the first of
the two customization points is number
traits it is intended to be customizable
just like say pointer traits or
allocator traits are customizable no
they don't well this is their interface
right this is their interface this is
not their implementation one could
implement them in different ways I see
two questions a quotes you go first so
so concepts might be able to so the
question is is this a place to to use
concepts so we're still discussing this
and honestly I'm not super familiar with
concepts I don't know whether we could
take out this customization point number
traits entirely and and replace its
mission the mission that it fulfills
with concepts in the engine types or the
matrix types themselves it may be
possible that that that can be done okay
well we've not gotten that far yet sorry
there was Chris Peck okay yes that's
correct
so give me a second and you'll see let
me see
okay this implicitly defines the concept
right these are the things that have
I think by the time you get to actual
lwg whirring this would be a concept in
that work yes that that very well could
be so to answer to answer your question
let me get a few slides further and
you'll see how at least in this proposal
we propose that the predicate traits are
implemented I think they'll answer your
question okay these are some tag types
that define certain properties these are
useful for implementing engines I'm not
going to talk about what they are what
they mean they're not important to the
rest of the conversation but they are
part of the public interface so I
included them they may go away oh and by
the way I should say I didn't say this
at first and I neglected we're proposing
a new sub namespace math stood math that
these facilities would go into there's a
proposed area I think there's a proposal
for some constant some named constants
and stuff and that proposal also that
predates ours wants to put several
constants inside a stood math namespace
so we're sort of piggybacking on that
idea okay
so let's talk this is the engines that
are part of the proposals so far we have
a dynamically resizable vector and
matrix engine there are two template
parameters the element type and the
allocator type we have that in these
particular types on their storage we
have owning engines that for fixed size
internal storage we have a fixed size
vector engine a fixed size matrix engine
the vector engine has one template nan
type template parameter that specifies
how many elements are in the vector the
matrix engine has two which specify the
number of rows and columns we call this
this getting back to the term of fixed
type its fixed type because the number
of rows and columns are fixed and known
at compile time we also have some
examples a part of the proposal here of
non owning view style engines a matrix
column view a matrix row view and a
matrix transpose view
we have no particular reason it could be
so that's that's a subject that's a
question really that I intended so the
question is why did we use in 32 to
represent the size parameters we could
have used size T or some other number I
thought honestly I thought by using in
32 somebody in committee would raise the
question and say why didn't you use
something and then people would argue
about it and come back with a definitive
answer about what is the best integral
type to use there so it's sort of a it's
sort of a red flag to wave wave in front
of the bowl to get an answer about
something because I don't have any firm
feeling about it yeah I don't and I
didn't you know I'm I'm I'm scared that
it might launch into the whole sign
versus unsigned debate again in which
case I might have to slip out and get
something to eat and come back you know
after someone is left standing okay
I mentioned the matrix operation traits
I'll show you an implementation of that
it's forward declared here because for
vector and matrix it is the second
template parameter and it's defaulted so
vector and matrix have two template
parameters the first template parameter
is the engine type and now if we recall
the engine types are themselves
parametrized in terms of an element type
i wanted to minimize the number of
template parameters because i don't like
the way the containers are built so I'm
putting the element type in the engine
the second template parameter is the
operation traits type here it's
defaulted to matrix operation traits
which is the default set of operation
traits that the library provides so what
are the various were the various traits
right well as I mentioned we have four
arithmetic operations that we support
addition subtraction negation
multiplication for each of those
operations we provide a set of element
promotion traits we provide a set of
engine promotion traits you see on the
bottom there we provide a set of
arithmetic traits and you may ask
yourself you may ask me
Bob why do you have traits for different
operations right it's possible that one
mate somehow want to define a type such
that the resulting type promotion from
from adding two elements of type X is
different than subtracting or
multiplying two elements of type X like
John McFarland's elastic integer
proposal that I mentioned each integer
is parametrized but on the number of
bits that is used to represent the
integer if I have two 20 bit integers
and I add them together I get a 21 bit
integer if I have two 20 bit integers
and and I multiply them together I get a
40 bit integer if I have two 20 bit
integers and I subtract them well maybe
I get a 19 bit integer I don't know but
we provide this flexibility so that
users if they need to they can customize
these things to provide specific
performance for their specific types so
we have element promotion traits for
each of the four arithmetic operations
ends in promotion traits for the fourth
arithmetic operations and arithmetic
traits for the arithmetic operations
finally at the bottom we come to the
second customization point the matrix
operation traits selector this is the
type which in an aqua in an operator
decides what's my resulting operation
traits type and you'll see an example of
this in a few moments we have operators
this is the operator write addition for
vectors and matrices we have subtraction
for vectors and matrices we have
negation for vectors and matrices we
have multiplications so here we have
scalar multiplication and because we're
not assuming we're we are only assuming
that element types are non commutative
rings we have both forms right
we have so we have here multiplication
of vector x matrix and matrix times
vector and so when vector pre multiplies
matrix we assume that the vector is a
row vector when a vector post multiplies
a matrix we assume that it's a column
vector yes
Zak sorry couldn't hear Lee that is up
to the implementer so yes it depends
right if you if you are implementing too
if you're implementing addition for
example of the fixed size engine you
know at compile time if the size is if I
have a three by four and I'm adding it
to a three by five
you can static assert that right if I
have a fixed size engine and I'm adding
it to and I'm using it in an operation
where I'm adding a dynamically resized
engine then I would need to maybe throw
an exception or do something at run time
right okay right okay so so I anticipate
that yes we would specify that
exceptions get thrown at least for the
engines that are provided as part of the
standard right yes
so the decision that we've made and we
got support from this in Kona was to
have one vector type and the meaning of
the vector be dependent on the context
so as I said if if I'm multiplying a
vector in a matrix the Assumption in
that case is that the vector if the
vector x matrix is a row vector matrix
times vector the vector is a column
vector yes you could I think that that's
an implementation issue there's nothing
that prevents one from instantiating a
matrix that has one row or one column
and in that case you get the outer
product certainly the inner product
gives you a one by one matrix right if
you're willing to live with a one by one
matrix as the result of an inner product
sure so so the question is I'm
implicitly broadcasting the vector
depending on its context the shape of
the vector the orientation of the vector
depends on its position as an operand in
the expression that's all I'm trying to
get out here one more question I really
have to move on okay all right finally
there are some just to make it easy for
users there are some convenience aliases
deine vector and dying matrix which are
basically just take one template
parameter and default there allocator
type similar to say vector or list and
there is FS vector and FS matrix which
you know cut down on some of the typing
for
you know ordinary users so let's look at
numeric traits the purpose of numeric
traits is to specify and test the
properties of numeric types again
intended to be partially specialized
about this is copied from earlier slide
the things that are highlighted are
things that I'm going to show you so
first I'd like to show you an
implementation detail of how I might go
about implementing number traits so
hidden in a detail namespace I have
something called built in number traits
and non number traits for built in
number traits I have three nested type
deaths his field is ring is non
commutative ring and for that particular
type I set them all to be stood true
type for non number traits I set them
all to be false type inside inside the
detail namespace as well I create a
little parametrized helper alias which
looks at the type T and if it's an
arrhythmic tick type it returns the type
built in number traits and then using
stood conditional here to in effect
return the type if it's not a built-in
arithmetic type it returns the type not
number traits and then my implementation
below for the primary template of number
traits it's publicly derived from my
helper trait which looks at the type of
the implementation so if the
implementation is an arithmetic type
it's going to be derived from it's going
to be publicly derived from built in
number traits if it's not an arithmetic
type type it's going to be publicly
derived from non-number traits this is
not necessarily the best implementation
but it's one that works now is
sufficient for my purposes as an example
another example of how it might be used
I could imagine
the standard including a specialization
for complex of T so complex of T would
have number traits that are the traits
that are associated with the underlying
element type of the complex number right
so the question was about his field is
ring is non commutative ring how could
those be used well the idea is to
leverage the fields that are part of
number traits which is the customization
point and they would it be applied to
the predicate traits so you don't you
don't specialize the predicate traits
you specialize number trades because the
predicate traits depend on number traits
and that way you get the predicate
traits is field is ring is non
commutative ring to provide answers
based on your custom numeric type and
then finally predicate traits type for
matrix elements here for now we've
chosen May relaxes but we've chosen to
say a type T is a legitimate matrix
element if T is an arithmetic type or T
meets the definition of field doesn't
necessarily need to be a field I think
it may be sufficient for matrices and
vectors to be non commutative ranks it
may need to be fields for computing
determinants and higher order things but
for these simple operations rings may be
sufficient and then there's a helper
trait you know just two helper type
alias
so let's look at the engines I'm going
to quickly go through three different
engines the dynamically resizable matrix
engine the fixed size matrix engine and
the matrix transpose view as an example
of a View engine so the matrix engine
the top of the Matrix engine looks
remarkably similar to stood vector I'm
here at the top I'm using the type tag
that this is a resizable matrix engine
tag I have nested aliases for element
type and value type allocator type
reference pointer Const reference cons
pointer the kind of things that you see
in the standard containers difference
type one thing that we do different from
the standard containers is we
distinguish between the size type and
the index type you know there's this
hole size T versus s size T discussion
and the question of whether or not
member functions that return size should
be returning size or signed or unsigned
types so we basically say all right
we're going to punt on this question for
four member functions that return sighs
we're going to use size type for member
functions used for indexing we're going
to use indexing type and for now they're
all going to be the same type they're
going to be put or div T we also here
have a nested type def called size tuple
which is just a pair of two sizes for
convenience so they can return the size
of a matrix in one object instead of
instead of two could I get it from the
allocator type I could do that I could
do that I chose not to there's no reason
why it couldn't be done
Zach stop doing what so Zach's comment
is that in this specifications for newer
containers and container adapters they
no longer extract size type and
difference type from the allocator
instead they specify it directly am I
getting that right okay
so moving on we also provide some nested
type deaths similar to what allocator
traits does for for specifying certain
properties about the engine is it fixed
size well in the case of dynamic
resizable no it's not
is it resizable yes it is it's true type
is it column major in this case no it's
not is it dense yes is it rectangular
yes is it row major yes this is not an
exhaustive or final set of properties
but it's an example of properties that
one might define about the engine we
also define view types and the view
types are instantiated in terms of the
engine so our column view type is the
matrix column view class instantiated in
terms of this engine same thing with row
view and transpose view all of the view
types are parameterized in terms of some
engine over which they provide a view
and then we've got you know the special
member functions and constructors very
straightforward for here for
instantiation the first near the bottom
the two constructors that take sizes you
know you can specify rows and columns or
rows and columns and wrote capacity and
column capacity in one shot you have the
member functions that you might expect
for indexing elements in a Const in a
Const fashion for returning the number
of columns and rows the size in this
case sizes return is that size tuple so
I can work with a tuple instead of
multiple calls doing individual things
same thing with the column capacity the
row capacity and the capacity of the
matrix in it in entirety again as a pair
of sizes in a size two yes they could be
they could be stood array there's no
reason why they could not be stood array
they chose tuple for now send me a note
so I remember to make that change okay
that's fine now that's that that's a
legitimate that's a very legitimate bit
of feedback there's always two sorry
been this one they are in this case so
that's that's so that's a good question
you know I've not worked at we've not
worked out all the rules for this
consider an engine some other type of
engine that represents a sparse matrix
it could be that they are both false
could they both be true I can't think of
an example on the off the top of my head
whether or not that that could be maybe
someone
for most use cases but there I guess I
was thinking of the case of a sparse
engine where they would both be false
okay so moving on mutable element access
so there are some member functions here
for mutating and moving around the
elements of the engine we have of course
mutable referencing we have functions
for doing assignments and swaps swapping
in swapping the contents of two engines
swapping two columns swapping two rows
we also have functions for reserving
excess capacity and for resizing to a
specific number of rows and columns or
resizing to a specific number of rows
and columns and specifying excess
capacity at the same time finally as a
possible not as specified but a possible
private implementation might look like
this where you have a pointer based on
the allocators pointer type that points
to some array of elements excuse me you
have the number of rows to columns Road
capacity column capacity and you
maintain a local instance of the
allocator let's look at the fixed size
matrix engine very similar the same but
different right so here we're going to
statically assert I think the yes
so we statically assert on the element
type to make sure it's a legitimate
matrix element and with fixed size
engine we do the same thing we also
statically assert on the number of rows
and columns to make sure they're greater
than or equal to one right we do the
same sort of business with the engine
category this is a mutable engine we
specify the element types reference
pointer constants indexing type just to
do something difference and I'm not
saying this as part of the
implementation just to make sure that
things compiled and work properly
and there weren't lots of errors that
will probably change later on so here is
a corresponding set of of those type
traits in this case fixed size is true
and resizable is false but call a major
density rectangularity row-major those
are the same the column view row view
and transpose view again those use the
view types instantiated in terms of the
fixed size matrix engine here the number
of you know we only have the special
member functions we have Const
referencing the conchs element access
and and Const accessors we have mutable
element access in the ability to change
elements but what we do not have is we
do not have resize or reserve the number
of rows and columns the row capacity and
call capacity is fixed therefore there
is no need to have resize or reserve as
member functions of this it is not
resizable it is not reservable therefore
those member functions don't exist in
this engine and in the bottom as a
possible implementation perhaps I have
some linear array of elements that has r
times c elements in it let's look at the
transpose view so here's a transpose u
it's parametrized in terms of some other
engine type and here it asserts that the
type ii t is a matrix engine and that's
a little helper trait that's not part of
the public interface and what it does is
it says alright I'm a Const matrix
engine tag which means I don't have any
mutable access to elements my element in
all my other properties element type
reference pointer index type those all
come from the engine the engine that I'm
parametrized in terminal in terms of and
all basically all of my properties are
parameterized in terms of the engine
right except for column major and row
major are swapped here right because
it's a transpose
and the column view of me is the column
view of me the transpose the row view is
the row view of me the transpose and I
can define a transpose type which is the
transpose of me a transpose and if you
actually do it if you do MTT you get
something that's equivalent to M right
it should work we have constant indexing
we have Const access and the
implementation is that I'm a view type
I'm an on owning view type I'm just
going to point to some instance of some
other engine and that engine could be
another transpose engine which points to
another engine right and I don't have it
on the slide but the indexing operator
is basically implemented in terms of
swapping the two indices of the
underlying engine so the matrix
operation traits all right we're going
to look at matrix the operation trades
and matrix so here's matrix operation
trades it's a container trades type it
contains them the promotion traits for
negation addition subtraction
multiplication engine promotion traits
for the four operations arithmetic
traits for the four operations and
that's it it's a container type that
holds all of the different kinds of
promotion that in arithmetic that needs
to be done that I want this type to use
so vector well this is stood colon colon
math colon colon vector and I'm not
looking forward to the bike shedding on
that all right so the important
properties of regarding element type
just like what the transpose you they
come from the engine right the engine
determines those things and so in the
case of vector there's really no
transpose in our conception of vector so
the transpose type is just a constant
reference to this object right the
hermitian type which is the hermitian
type is a vector
if the cop if the elements are complex
if the elements are non complex it's
just the transpose type and the idea
being is if it's if this complex vector
then you actually need to fill a vector
with the conjugate transpose of the
elements and return that by value right
whereas if they are if they are non
complex elements you can just the
transpose can be a reference to this
thing the other properties is fixed is
resizable they all take their cue from
the engine and the interface to the
vector is very similar to the interface
of the engine right with the difference
that in some of the Constructors we seen
a out some of the Constructors and yes
we seen a out in or out some of the
Constructors and assignment operators
based on whether or not the engine type
is resizable if the engine type is not
resizable than we seen a out the second
two constructors that you see there
right there's no sense in sending those
dimensions to a fixed size engine type
because it doesn't have constructors to
take those dimensions so we spin a those
away and you we do the same thing I
think we do the same thing we do the
same thing with reserve and resize if
the underlying engine type is not
resizable then we see no those things
out of the interface and the enable if
enable if resizable that's a private
implementation trait and so vector owns
an engine right Jeff
this one it returns it returns Const
reference constant force is defined by
the engine type it can be a value it's
up to your engine to define your engine
defines what reference and conscious
reference are so the vector is I'm
saying the vector make the vector
contains an engine right it's a wrapper
to the engine matrix is very similar you
know see that the same idioms the same
patterns occur over and over again one
interesting again again with the
hermitian type if it's a complex element
that the return type is a is a matrix if
it is not a complex element type the
return type for the hermitian function h
is the transpose type right and here
again we're spinning out the
Constructors that have to do with resize
ability we have the Const element access
we have here at the bottom we're seeing
the use of the view types for column and
row remember that column type is a
vector which is based on a matrix column
view and row type is a vector whose
engine is a matrix row view
then our element mutating operations and
some of those are Steen a doubt if the
underlying engine type is does not allow
a mutable access like for a matrix
that's instantiated in terms of a
transpose type does not allow mutable
access to the elements because the mate
the transpose type represents a
constructs Zack
that's a good question we'll get to that
that's a very good question we'll get to
that that yes the short answer is yes
all right size and capacity management
and containing the engine all right now
we got through sort of the boring stuff
this is what I think is the interesting
stuff how does it work hopefully this
will answer some questions let's add two
matrices let's suppose I have a dynamic
matrix a float and a fixed size matrix a
double and let's assume they're both
four by fours for the sake of argument
right well so this is the use of those
convenience alias as I mentioned this is
what I expect a lot of people would use
most of the time well what are those
things really well those are really
aliases for matrix of a dynamically
resizable matrix engine of float whose
allocators and allocator double who's
using the standard matrix operation
traits and similarly for the for the
second m2 which is a fixed size matrix
so let's call some function that puts
some values in those doesn't matter what
it does let's add them together so we
want to know what is the type of mr
specifically what is the element type in
my result what is the engine type of
that result and what is the operations
traits type of that result right so
what's that sorry we need to look at
this we're going to look at this
expression M 1 plus M 2 so this takes us
to the matrix addition operator there's
the signature it's got some stuff in it
some compile time stuff to help us
figure those questions out so the first
thing we do is we're going to try and
figure out what's the operation traits
for the resulting type and I'm going to
call this type alias for the matrix
operation trade selector
it's going to take me to use the matrix
operation traits template and the
selector underscore T is just a
convenience alias right matrix operation
trait selector is one of the
customization points
there's the primary template we provide
the specialization at the bottom if both
operation traits are the same then the
resulting operation traits type is t1 or
or is the same type we also provide
specializations for the case where one
or both operands are the default matrix
operation traits now if you supply a
matrix operation traits that's different
than the default we assume that that's
the one you want and that's the type
that's going to be used and so we have
the two partial specializations you see
at the top to cover that case we have
the full specialization at the bottom
that says alright if both our mates are
the default matrix operation traits then
the resulting operation traits is the
default right makes sense all right so
we've just determined what the operation
traits are for the result well we know a
priori we can you know by inspection
what the operand one type is we know
what the type is of the second operand
and I'm just spelling them out
explicitly here now we're going to go to
add traits and when we spell that out
this is the matrix addition traits that
we're going to use right we're telling
we're going to call matrix addition
traits and we're going to say matrix
addition traits the resulting operation
traits is matrix operation traits here
are the types of the two matrix operands
we drop into matrix addition traits
matrix addition traits says okay I'm
going to add two things and you see at
the bottom is a member function that
actually does the addition but before I
can add them I need to know what are the
what's the resulting engine cut type
right so I'm going to drop into matrix
addition traits or matrix engine matrix
addition engine traits I drop into this
this is the base class template this
template is applied when the system
doesn't know what the two types of
engines are but as it so happens we have
a partial specialization in the library
for the case where the left-hand operand
is a dynamically
sizeable engine and the right hand
operand is fixed size great this partial
specialization is the one that's going
to get matched I've matched it well the
engine says well I'll tell you what type
it is but first I need to know what's my
element type so then I go into the
matrix addition element traits and that
just sort of does the standard thing
that you might respect it says let the
type let the two types tell me what the
resulting type is and so I look at the
deckle type of the deco vowel of
addition and you see the little work
through the logic there at the bottom
okay well my two types I've got a float
in a double add them together the
resulting type is double great I know my
element type is double so come back up
element type is double alligator tape
alligator type this is just a little
helper traits that BRE binds the
alligator
remember the alligator was an alligator
float so now I'm going to rebind it to
alligator of double and now I can
determine what my engine type is and in
this trait I've made the decision that
if I add if I have one operand the left
operand is dynamic and the right
operated stick size my result is a
dynamically resizable engine that's my
engine type great now I know my engine
type I know my operation traits type by
inspection because the operator told me
what it was now I can compute my
resulting type the type of the matrix so
the resulting type is going to be a
matrix a dynamically resizable matrix of
double whose operation traits are the
matrix operation traits and that's the
type that's going to be returned from
this member function add so I've gone
through some compile time calculations
to figure out what's my resulting
element type what's my engine type
what's my resulting math object type
alright great I return for that now I
want to do the addition at some point
later this gets called at run time right
so I have the static function it's
getting called it might look something
like this right
very simple there's some code to make
sure that the sizes match I instantiate
my result type maybe
I add some code there to make sure that
the size of the result the that mr gets
resized to be the right size to hold the
result of the operation
I hit err 8 over the two matrices and
add the result in return it this is a
trivial sort of strawman implementation
of how that might work the important
thing is that all of the types are
promoted and what you would expect them
to be I returned that I'm done so now I
know what the resulting type is does
that make sense all right this is easy
because everything is default let's look
at something that's a little harder and
talk about real customization right all
of this machinery is not necessary if
everything matches if all you needed to
do was determine hey I'm always going to
use dynamically resizable matrices and
all I need to do is figure out the
element type you don't need all this
machinery but suppose I have a custom
element type I've created a class new
num it doesn't matter what it is but it
purports to be a number right so I have
a nice member function interface with
all of the arithmetic operations the
self assignment operations and unary
negation and addition that you might
expect and I've defined a bunch of
binary operators and I've gone to the
trouble of figuring out what the
resulting type should be in the case
where I have mixed expressions and I've
decided hey if I'm adding a new num to
some other type my results always going
to be a new num but the important thing
is that I can use that element traits
promotion deckle type deckle val
expression on this and I will get a type
answer out of it right so how do i
integrate this so our goal is to have a
matrix with elements of type noonim that
participates in arithmetic expressions
how do i integrate it well my type
noonim is in my namespace in my name
space i'm going to specialize i'm going
to specialize the number traits type and
in this case I've decided that new num
is a non commutative ring it's a ring in
its field and I set those to true type
that's all I need to do and keeping in
mind
that that this operator has been defined
as for noonim if I have a dynamic matrix
afloat and a fixed size matrix of noonim
my resulting type mr in that expression
is going to be a dynamically resizable
matrix whose element type is new known
so I've done the element promotion to
new nom I've done the engine promotion
from fixed size and dynamic - dynamic
and I've returned the correct math type
right this is an easy example of
customization
what about custom element promotion
suppose for some reason I want to
promote the result of any float float
addition to double anytime two floats
are added I want to promote I don't want
to I don't want the result to be float I
want it to be doubled alright how do I
do that
I'm going to create a new element
addition traits right and in that given
two types of float I'm going to say my
returning my resulting element type is
double there's a new traits type that
exists in my namespace they just happen
to have the signature template signature
that matches that of the default traits
and I'm going to create a new operation
traits type and in my operation traits
type inside of it I'm going to bundle my
new element addition traits and I'm
going to use the I'm going to use the
expected name element addition traits
and I'm going to set the type alias
equal to the custom addition traits that
I just created right all this stuff is
my custom stuff and it exists in my
namespace I haven't touched anything in
stood math so now I'm going to
instantiate a matrix fixed size matrix
dynamically resizable matrix and that
used the new custom operation traits
notice the right side template parameter
and a dynamically resizable matrix that
uses the default matrix operation trades
and I'm going to do those arithmetic
operations what are the results going to
be what are the result types well
they're what you would expect them to be
for mr1 if I'm adding
M 1 to M 1 I expect it to be a fixed
sized engine but I expect the element
type to be double because my element
promotion trait says I'm adding two
floats I want to double and the same
thing happens if I do it for a diet if
I'm adding a dynamically resizable
matrix to the fixed size matrix but
what's really interesting is the third
case where I have a matrix that's using
the default operation traits and I have
a matrix that using my customized
operation trades because of the way we
set define the trait selector my custom
traits are going to take precedence over
the default traits and that's why my
result type here is going to be my
custom traits type because the
specialization had it both ways if
custom traits was first in default
traits was second or vice versa in both
of those cases in the traits selection
specialization it picked the custom
traits if you have to custom traits
that's the reason why matrix operation
traits the matrix operation trait
selector is a customization point
specifically for the case where you have
to custom traits I can't decide what the
resulting operation traits should be you
have to decide yes oh oh I'm sorry
that is the internally held type is
double I'm sorry that's a cut and paste
error that's a cut and paste error yes
yes good point thank you for pointing
out these are not floats these are
doubles this is you know Bob cutting and
pasting at 3:00 a.m. yeah here it's the
matrix engine is holding a double but I
cut and paste it in the wrong as I cut
typed in these comments these should
actually be allocator of double
no the traits don't have an allocator
type the engine promotion traits we
rebound the allocator from alligator
floats alligator double okay I've got a
few more minutes if you want to stick
around it's probably five minutes left
all right
I promise to go quickly the engine type
similar idea say I want to create a new
fixed size engine I create what I would
do is create my own and I want to apply
it to addition I would create my own
addition traits type I would add a
partial specialization to detect that in
expressions and I actually I'm going to
add partial specializations to detect
the case where I'm using my new fixed
size type with the with the standard one
and in all three cases my resulting
engine type is going to be my new fixed
size type I'm going to add those engine
addition traits to my custom operation
traits right and so now when I have
addition operations and I hope I cut and
pasted this right all of my floats are
going to be promoted to doubles and in
the case where both engines are fixed
I'm my resulting ninja type is going to
be my new engine type and in the case
where it's dynamic engine it'll be a
dynamic engine and cut and paste it
wrong again at the bottom that's a
double at the bottom but the important
point is for the first three expressions
my engine the element promotion applied
so I got float and float and got a
double my engine promotion applied I got
a fixed size matrix engine of test type
and and in the bottom I got a
dynamically resizable engine whose
allocator really is double customer
arithmetic I think this is the thing
that people are going to be most
interested in I'm going to create a
custom addition trace type and here I'm
really going to know I'm really going to
drill down I'm going to say that in the
case where I have a fixed size matrix
engine my new engine and I have matrices
of double and my size is three by four
only in that case do I want to apply
my customized ad operation at the bottom
of the traits there you could make it
whatever you want it to be it it depends
on the level of creativity that you want
to go to with custom adding specialist
at full and partial specializations of
the traits so anyways let me go quickly
so here here I'm going to use my new
addition traits and here I'm going to
have a fixed size matrix of my test
engine a float and one of double here
I'm going to get the expected sizes the
only difference is going to be in the
first two cases one or both of my
operands was the end was the matrix
engine type of float so I'm going to
call my standard matrix addition traits
add member function only in the third
case where both operands had the engine
type fixed engine type of double of
three four and in that case I'm going to
call my custom arithmetic operator so in
this particular instance I created a
traits type and a specialization that
only gets called in this one particular
circumstance this particular engine of
this particular size and in that one and
only case my custom Edition gets called
in every other case every other case the
regular edition gets called so I'm able
to customize at a varied level of a very
narrow or even greater level of
granularity it depends on how creative
you want to be quickly ongoing work
concept if ocation yes concepts need to
be looked at and thought about
integration with MD span we've talked
about using MD span as a basis for
representing some of the engines I think
that could work we've talked about using
MD span as a lingua franca for
communicating sizes and dimensions
between things other parts of the
library integration with executor z-- to
be done support for concurrency whether
it's executor Zoar some other
concurrency mechanism the idea of having
generic execution contexts
getting to your question we need to
build proof-of-concept sets of engines
arithmetic traits that employ expression
templates and also that demonstrate
concurrency there's nothing in the
architecture that prevents you from
writing a set of expression templates in
fact if you think about it the transpose
engine in a sense is an expression
template right there's nothing to keep
you from creating the rest just you know
in my copious spare time I've been too
lazy to do it right
all right that's it thank you for for
staring staying with me I know it was
very long
[Applause]